février 2011 la colère gronde sur la
place tahrir symbole du pouvoir en plein
centre du caire
il y a dix ans le peuple égyptien se
soulevait contre le président hosni
moubarak
emboîtant ainsi le pas à la tunisie un
événement historique qui voyait émerger
de nouveaux leaders dans les rues dans
tout le pays ou sur la place tahrir les
gens manifestent avec une motivation
très forte
ils ont leurs revendications le
président devrait démissionner il doit
quitter son poste et son régime ont déjà
échoué par la volonté de ce peuple il
doit démissionner et une nouvelle ère
politique doit s'ouvrir
trois semaines seulement après le début
du mouvement le 11 février 2011 le
peuple sort vainqueur hosni moubarak est
destitué après 30 ans au pouvoir
s'ensuit alors une période de transition
avec le mouvement islamiste des frères
musulmans et son leader mohamed morsi
une présidence d'à peine un an
écourtée en 2013 par un coup d'état les
militaires s'emparent du pouvoir et
impose le général abdel fattah al-sisi
élu président en 2014
depuis huit ans les espoirs de liberté
et de justice sociale s'aménuisent face
à un pouvoir toujours plus autoritaire
nous avons connu une nouvelle escalade
globale en termes de répression du
paysage des droits humains en général en
egypte avec l'arrestation de nos
collègues de l'initiative égyptienne
pour les droits individuels qui est
l'une des plus importantes organisations
de défense des droits humains qui
subsistent encore dans le pays
la nation mais quand tu es au caire où
ailleurs aucune commémoration de
l'événement n'est prévu d'ailleurs que
ce soit dans les médias ou dans les
livres
la révolution égyptienne n'a pas droit
de cité quant au gouvernement il
renforce son contrôle interdisant tout
rassemblement en particulier sur la
place tahrir
car désormais c'est la menace d'une
nouvelle révolution qui plane au dessus
du pays